on attendait clint eastwood ou crise
mendes et à la surprise générale et de
risques aux larmes et la palme un jeune
danois l'ont 6000 est inconnue
bibliobs
en d'autres temps en un pays lointain
un père cherchant désespérément à fuir
son passé et son fils roland de se bâtir
un avenir se lance dans l'aventuré d'une
vie nouvelle
pour moi c'est d'abord une histoire
entre un père et son fils une relation
très forte très riez pas contre ces deux
personnages mais c'est aussi un film sur
les migrants sur les suédois qui sont
venus chercher une terre promise au
danemark avec plein d'espoir au coeur et
qui ont été cruellement déçu et j'espère
que ce film aidera à comprendre la
tragédie du sort des migrants qui mérite
plus de considération on leur en donne
en général la performance de max von
sidow dans le film c'est de nous faire
partager le poids de sa propre
expérience de sa maturité
au lieu de cultiver simplement son ego
comme acteur il est formidable parce
qu'il s'intéresse d'abord à la jc
après l'oscar du festin de babette plus
gabriel axel la palme de pelles et le
conquérant est la deuxième grande
récompense que l'udc cette année par le
cinéma danois